the world is my idea this is a truth
which holds good for everything that
leaves and knows though man alone can
bring it into reflective an abstract
consciousness this is how Arthur
Schopenhauer introduces us to his most
celebrated work the world as will and
representation such a potent way to
introduce your audience your inner world
requires quite some audacity in
Schopenhauer so case to consider the
amount of that throughout his life he
was the philosopher that preceded
Nietzsche and succeeded cont this three
philosophy moguls created a continuum of
critical thinking and life defining
concepts that influenced the Western
thought like fumé Schopenhauer was a man
of great depth who tried to understand
the maladies of the human condition and
proposed pragmatic ways to deal with it
through his writings I discovered
notions that not only reengineer the
ways we think about ourselves and our
relationship with reality but also
transcend the way we view the very
fabric of reality Schopenhauer's work
was dense and he language assertive he
was a pessimist but also a pragmatist he
detested puerile arguments and wanted to
get to the gist of things most of his
postulates emerged from a strong desire
to live a life that was within his scope
of understanding but also faced the
truth about reality notwithstanding how
harsh this may be he was a great admirer
of counting philosophy and more
specifically his ideas about the thing
in itself and transcendental idealism
the thing in itself is quite
self-explanatory the thing in itself is
the object as it is regardless of how we
perceive it with regards to
transcendental idealism Schopenhauer
described it as a distinction between
the phenomenon and the thing in itself
in essence what comes supports is that
the human experience is totally
subjective and disengaged from the
nature of the phenomena will perceive
for instance we can observe and interact
with a dog but we can't really have a
dog experience as a dog actually
perceives it extrapolating from these
two concepts he attempts to evolve
concept of perception and reality by
adding the notion of well in the
equation the will of Schopenhauer
understands it is the expression of the
desire of all nature to pursue and
propagate life without will there can be
no life but it is also through will that
most of mankind's misery and suffering
is manifested we as humans are consumed
by our drives drives as a sexual desires
pursuit of pleasure and need for
interaction will to power the
elucidation of aesthetics and much more
they are all integral constituents of
the way we operate and they all fall
under the umbrella of what sovereign
power refers to as the will to live life
isn't just an abstract concept for us it
is an experience manifested through a
plethora of wheels that are intertwined
in an attempt to form an ensemble that
justifies the reasoning behind our
existence but this conglomerate of
individual wheels isn't limited solely
to the human dimension it can be found
in the whole of nature in ways we cannot
comprehend you to our limited perception
this is what Schopenhauer calls the
wheel with a capital W and this limited
perception according to Schopenhauer is
the source of our misery and suffering
the supreme principle of the universe is
apprehensible only through introspection
and through the transcendence of egoism
that it's human is endowed with ego is
the enemy an enemy that can be
confronted
only through self-awareness empathy and
compassion the curse that has befallen
our species is that we cannot really
three ourselves from the will the will
can be released or negated but it can
change within this inauspicious
landscape we ought to attempt to operate
in the most effective way possible
it sounds like an arduous challenge it
feels like groping and fumbling in the
dark but Schopenhauer Adam rates that
the denial of the will to live might be
the only way to salvation from suffering
this pessimistic outlook towards life is
observed all over his narrative and it
was because of this tone that many refer
to him as the philosopher of pessimism
the absurdity of reality has always been
the main area of interest for most
Western philosophers Schopenhauer in his
attempt to create meaning out of this
absurdity illuminated a very pessimistic
rhetoric take for example the following
passage from the world as will and
representation into this world to this
scene of tormented and agonized beings
who only continue to exist by devouring
each other
in which therefore every ravenous beast
is the living grave of thousands of
others and it's self maintenance is a
chain of painful deaths and in which the
capacity for filling pain increases with
knowledge and therefore reaches its
highest degree in man a degree which is
the higher the more intelligent the man
is to this world it has been so to apply
the system of optimism and demonstrate
to us that it is the best of all
possible worlds the absurdity is
clearing it is self-evident that he's in
her world is tormented you to the
absurdity that it's prevalent all over
our existence this nihilistic approach
connotes an alignment with the idea of
determinism deuteron ability to
influence the wheel however he doesn't
give up he understands that there is an
escape even if this can be found on a
metaphysical level not merely that the
world exists but still more that it is
such a miserable and melancholy world is
that romantic problem of metaphysics
here he is tapping into the world of
metaphysics by realizing that there
needs to be another dimension to our
existence one we will never experience
if we keep recycling the same thinking
modus ad infinitum the life of every
individual viewed as a whole and in
general and when only its most
significant features are emphasized is
really tragedy but gone through in
detail it has the character of a comedy
sarcasm is also a weapon he uses from
time to time in order to alleviate the
significance of the tragedy of the human
condition through self-awareness we come
to understand that our Creator has
either a very sadistic taste or that
he/she eat or they are testing us when
we realize how tragic that is we end up
thinking that it could all be a travesty
of some sort having to deal with this
level of absurdity makes you
they're angry or you laugh at it for if
anything in the world is desirable so
desirable that even the dull and
uneducated heard in its more reflective
moments would value it more than silver
and gold this that ray of light should
fall on the obscurity of our existence
in that we should obtain some
information about this enigmatic life of
ours in which nothing is clear except
its misery and vanity eventually he ends
up adopting a more pragmatic stance
lamenting can only get one so far and
after we get over our anger we need to
face the truth and deal with it
Schopenhauer emphasizes that in the face
of a world filled with endless strife
our only escape is of universal moral
awareness that will allow us to achieve
a more balanced frame of mind by merging
Christian precepts and Indian wisdom he
attempts to lay out some major
principles of moral awareness and can
lead humanity to a more tranquil state
principles such as the repudiation of
violence altogether the idea that one
should treat others as one - its oneself
the transcendence of egoism the fight
against suffering in the world and the
perennial cultivation of compassion as
an absolute humanitarian doctrine after
testing the truth of human nature from a
moral standpoint
Schopenhauer realizes that there are
only two paths that can help one deal
with this conundrum esthetics and
asceticism aesthetics is presented as
the antidote to the ugliness of
suffering it is through aesthetic
perception that the transcendence of ego
can manifest itself for with aesthetics
we can evaluate an idea beyond our
earthly interpretation of reality this
idea is analogous to the idea of
sublimation that Freud put forth during
his time orienting consciousness toward
states of mind that are less
individuated and more cosmic has always
inspired great thinkers hence the strong
affinity towards Eastern philosophies
only through the pure contemplation
which becomes absorbed entirely in the
object are the ideas comprehended and
the nature of genius consists precisely
in the preeminent ability for such
contemplation this demands a complete
forgetting of our own person we can
temporarily emancipate ourselves from
what the will dictates through an
aesthetic
experience on the occurrence of an
aesthetic appreciation the will thereby
vanishes entirely from consciousness
asceticism on the other hand that as is
as the more secure attitude since
according to Schopenhauer aesthetic
perception due to its transient nature
is most of the time short lived as a
decision can result in the denial
towards our will to live that's allowing
us to fight against the suffering that
the will attempts to impose upon us by
the expression asceticism which I have
already used so often I understand in
the narrower sense this deliberate
breaking of the will by refusing the
agreeable and looking for the
disagreeable the voluntarily chosen way
of life of penance and softest iseman
for the concert modification of the
wheel the issue usually highlighted as a
contradiction in this way of thinking is
that the suffering that asceticism tries
to assuage but a toxically leads to
different types of suffering like
isolation anxiety antisocial behavior
sexual oppression and so on regardless
of how asceticism is portrayed or
exercised soap on how it truly believes
that the ascetic struggle is the
ultimate struggle against the will and
this acting itself can give us a modicum
of what self transcendence might
actually entail many prominent
philosophical figures criticized sopin
howard's work and claim that there are
numerous contradictions in his
philosophy this is inevitable when one
possesses such a genius in the art of
absurd reasoning the world in and of
itself is full of contradictions and we
should all just embrace the absurdity of
that fact
Schopenhauer with his works has
rightfully earned the place in the
pantheon of philosophers across space
and time in my first introduction to him
he made me a pessimist but then he
helped me enjoy life his words can be
mesmerizing and can alleviate the pain
of existence for most of us insofar as
we open our hearts and our minds to them
hi everyone I won't lie to you I was
ignoring Schopenhauer for many years
because I was a hardcore Nietzsche
devotee and that ended me somewhat
snowbeast towards other philosophers
there was such a naive assertion since
its alienated me from one of the most
important thinkers in human history
Schopenhauer for me epitomizes the s
of the quintessential philosopher and
this becomes more vivid every time I
read the world as will and
representation I say huge thank you for
making it to the end of the video and
for supporting my work I want to offer
you the chance to experience the same
feeling I will send a copy of the world
as will and representation
Schopenhauer's most celebrated work to
one of you all you need to do is to
follow me on instagram subscribe to this
channel get notifications and message me
on instagram confirming that you did all
that with a screenshot i will randomly
pick the winner and a week from now and
i will contact you in your Instagram
accounts so stay tuned again thanks for
watching see you in the next video
you